-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody. You're here.
You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
Thanks for being here.
Yeah, welcome.
Enjoy yourself.
Well guys,
I want to wish everyone
a happy Martin Luther King Jr
Day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's such an important holiday.
And of course, leaders
from all across the country
have put out statements.
President Biden said...
Vice President Harris said...
Congressman George Santos
said...
-Aww.
-So that was nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Meanwhile, today, Biden spoke
in an event honoring MLK,
and Dr. King's daughter-in-law
was there.
It was actually her birthday.
So, Biden decided to sing
to her.
Let's see how that went.
-On somebody's birthday,
you sing happy birthday.
You ready?
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday dear...
[ Mumbles ] ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
-First rule -- first rule.
Don't start singing
"Happy Birthday"
unless you know
the person's name.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that must have been
real special for [mumbles].
[ Laughter ]
There's a reason why the
birthday song at TGI Fridays
doesn't have the name in it.
Rookie move, Joe.
Every singer knows
that when you forget the lyric,
that's when you point the mic
towards the crowd.
It's like,
♪ Happy birthday, dear... ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Happy birthday ♪
And you do that.
I mean, come on. Alright.
Let's give him a break.
It's not like Biden's done this
before.
-♪ Happy birthday, [mumbles] ♪
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. [ Laughs ]
-Yep, Biden spoke
for 30 minutes.
When he wasn't belting out
"Happy Birthday,"
he was doing that
weird whispering thing again.
Which brings us
to the latest installment of
"Joe Biden: Whisperer in Chief."
♪♪
-You know, all these new IRS
agents we have is because
[whispering] they fired
a lot of them.
If any of these bills
happen to reach my desk,
[whispering] I will veto them.
I think the highest individual
loan was 1.2 million
or something. [Whispering] I
didn't hear a word.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[Whispering] He's the best.
[Normally] Speaking of Biden,
over the weekend,
five more pages of classified
documents were found
at his home in Delaware.
Yep, this year,
instead of an Easter egg hunt,
they're going to send the kids
over to Biden's home
to look for more documents.
It's like,
"Found one under the sofa."
"Alright, hand it over."
At this point, they've found
documents in so many places,
it's like we're playing Clue.
It's like North Korea's
nuclear codes in the garage
with the Corvette.
Yeah, I got it!
Yup, the scandal has gotten
so big, today,
Hunter Biden told his dad,
"I can't be seen with you
right now."
Hey, I saw that Johnson &
Johnson has recently scaled back
production on
their COVID vaccine.
That's like Hooters saying
that they're taking
kale chips off the menu.
[ Laughter ]
"No kale chips?
I'll just get 50 wings."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is cool --
I read that the latest Gen Z
obsession is using flip phones.
Yeah, tons of young adults
are buying flip phones
I think it's great.
I used to love my flip phone.
-Oh, yeah.
You love your flip phone?
What else?
-What else?
I mean, I like flip phones.
I like flying drones.
-That's cool. What else?
-I like hot scones.
I like garden gnomes.
I like watching
"Game of Thrones,"
"Home Alone," and "Yellowstone"
on my own with an ice cream cone
in Bayonne.
I like hair combed, beard full
grown, and riding the cyclone
with Tommy Lee Jones, reading
poems covered in cologne.
I like Ray Brone,
I like Carl Malone,
ozone, singing baritone
while Sly Stallone
plays trombone
and Roman Grosjean chaperones
about clones and overdue loans.
But you know what I really love?
-Who?
-The Rolling Stones.
2, 3...
♪ [ Singing indistinctly ] ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, there's a lot
of pop culture news right now.
"Avatar 2" is doing great
at the box office.
The new season of "The Bachelor"
starts next week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sarah Jessica Parker was just
seen filming
the "Sex and the City" spin off
with the actor who plays Aiden.
There's gonna be a sequel
to the horror movie "M3GAN."
-Wait a second.
-What is it, Mark?
-Did you just say
that Sarah Jessica Parker,
A.K.A. Carrie Bradshaw, was
spotted filming
the "Sex and the City" spin-off
A.K.A. "And Just Like That"
alongside the actor who plays
Aiden, A.K.A. John Corbett?!
-Yeah, I did.
And here's the photo.
Yeah.
-Wow.
Aiden is coming back
in Carrie's life.
That's big.
Pun intended.
Who else is coming back?
What about her old boyfriend,
Patrick?
-I'm not really sure.
-Well, what about Burger?
-I don't know.
-How about Howie?
-I have no idea.
-What about Kurt, John, Jake,
or Ray?
-Couldn't tell you.
-What about Wade, Keith, Seth,
Jeremy, Sam, Bill, or Jeremiah?
-I really don't know.
-Okay. Well, what about Shawn,
Vaughn, Dr. Brad,
Ben, Joe, or Alexander?
-Beats me.
-How about John, Jordan, Jason,
Tucker, or Parker?
-Mark, I don't know.
-I made up those last five.
You're useless.
Look, if you're not going
to give us any answers,
we're out of here.
Come on, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-And just like that,
he was gone.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, guys, I heard that LG
is recalling their 86-inch
smart TVs because they can
tip over and trap people.
[ Light laughter ]
"Trap?" You know the LG people
went on thesaurus.com
like, "What's a better word
than 'crush?'
Trap."
[ Laughter ]
Trapped?
Hey, guys, on Friday night,
somebody in Maine
won the $1.3 billion
Mega Millions jackpot.
And get this --
it's the first time someone
has won the prize in Maine.
In fact, the state is so excited
they're considering
changing their
official welcome sign.
Right now it says...
But they might change it to...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
But they're also considering...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, there is...
That's what I'm talking about.
Well, listen to this --
a new survey found
that four out of five people
would work on vacation
if it meant they could
have a longer trip.
And Biden said, "Take it
from me, you're better off
leaving your work at work."
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, guys, it is Monday,
the start of a brand-new week,
and I think we all could use
a little encouragement
to get things going
on the right foot.
With that in mind, it's time
for some Monday Motivations.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Monday motivations ♪
♪♪
-Hey, your hair looks
great today.
[ Applause ]
You're going to have
an amazing week.
[ Applause ]
When you're fishing
and you throw one back,
its swims over to its friends
like, "Guys, it happened!
I finally met Andrew."
[ Applause ]
When you zone out
waiting for your pizza rolls,
your microwave is like, "OMG,
is he looking at me?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Your JV soccer coach still talks
about that goal you made.
Well, almost made.
[ Laughter and applause ]
When you sit down next to
someone on an airplane,
they're like, "Jackpot.
Hello, future husband."
[ Applause ]
You didn't hear it,
but one time,
your favorite teacher
accidentally called you son.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, the gym turned you
away on January 1st
because they didn't want to give
people unrealistic expectations.